yeah now they're great jeans but they
ripped in though they ripped in the knee
and I think that was on purpose but
daddy's a little too old to wear
something that they can have the ribs
dude can't have the rips Carol rips
can't put a fin on the back here Honda
Civic there are certain things you can't
do when you're at your age Justin any
have braces can't abrasive seen braces
on on a man of a certain age a bummer
yeah
a man of a certain age can't wear a
shirt open you can't wear you can't wear
super tight jeans at a certain age you
still can't wear bracelets you know it
surrounds your necklace isn't cool on
the older guys bracelets or bracelets I
saw i sat next to a dude Christmas it
was older than me he had the lids on his
eyes and he had a bead bracelet on and
he was a business guy wasn't he wasn't
dressed he wasn't dressed the normal way
he was just wearing beads around us I
was like you might be because whenever I
see a guy like that whenever I see a
dude who's dressed normal but then he's
got a little something
he's got like a a necklace with like a
quartz or he's got like a couple
bracelets but he's dressed like he sells
insurance I go huh you might be a
[ __ ] druid you might be a [ __ ]
closet man which you might maybe you
won't be you might be worshipping Satan
when you're off on your free time or the
other thing is sometimes you that
businessman with like the turquoise
bracelet or one pinky dude [ __ ] he
[ __ ] oh dude I got fob he's wearing it
cuz like his 18 year old side piece told
me he's a swinger it's what he is I just
[ __ ] up time smells smells a little
bit like suntan oil from change this
chest even though he's 58 yeah works out
like a [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah
little stiff in the back of a struggle
spray tan lifts weights but he doesn't
stretch so he's a little tight but his
dick works and he's dirty he's a guy
he's got getting your mud whistle all
right first place he goes in the mud
whistle all right
I met a girl in Florida
yep right it's always Florida well the
dude there's two weirdest girls there
were two words things girls have says
one girl said my favorite thing is to
have my ass headon that was fine
I was like all right that's good
now yeah not not gonna do that probably
I don't know what's going on hot enough
on me and then I then another girl who's
from Colombia told me she wanted to
drink my blood so those are the two
things those are the two things why I
went well now I'm not sure what to do
now I like that you're into me that much
that you want to drink my blood you want
to drink my blood that's intense did I
ever tell you that's right no I thought
it was this past weekend no no this was
a long time ago
I just wanted just so hot I just want to
drink your blood oh well listen mr. van
Pierre a the food not into it
impossibly hot dude what hell yeah at
least at least my wrists that seems very
dangerous the old Nikki Oh Mike Nikki
pooja that's a girl who's into what man
something like crying something you
don't turn on oh you mean when a girl's
crying girls cry yeah well III my dick
is let's get all pouty yes yes that's
terrible
hit that happens I start my actually do
like Nick oh I haven't actually cried be
like oh man listen let me help ya way to
make you feel good lips would be all
full she looked all the door oh [ __ ] man
yeah so she you guys are like off see
around a sad time and then what do you
guys just hanging out a ton trying to
like yeah all the friends are together
but then meaner we're always like super
close anyways so just yeah just happened
naturally and there's no way well you
know there's a there's a thing called
oxytocin which is a bonding chemical so
when you're under duress so soldiers and
war
athletes in competition with others
pregnant moms that that's what that's
what the child yeah it's the same
chemical it's created in times of great
stress competition wherever and that
creates bonds between people that's a
very deep on criminals in criminal gangs
if they're not sociopaths that tend to
be where they get they get tight your
point with fighting too it's like you
you know even with Travis Browne with
all the ill-will we had to each other
bad blood once you go through that
experience afterwards
we [ __ ] man
wait hold on want to back up for a
second
well no you what are you talking Wyatt
you want to come out now
no but for reals we were cool oh you
were oh yeah
look you shake my hands I hear you all
right again yeah you shattered my lip
whatever oh yeah yeah man listen even
even through that so that's where you
guys create this I see me better alone
say this and I have a witness to this
which is John Leguizamo I'm with John
Leguizamo and Sean Penn comes up and
starts talking to us I swear to God I
didn't know it was Sean Penn I thought
it was an older guy yeah all due respect
I love sharp edges but it's Sean Penn I
swear to god that's how I felt he was
having I don't know he was very very
thin yeah and he's just older you know
people do it after he shot milk yeah
whatever the [ __ ] it was and I seem to
have a limp he was walking there said
something when I looked like he had a
stiff back I love the guy I'm not
dissing him I'm a huge fan but III this
is so lame that I even saying it but he
said Brian Brian Brian is a comic yeah
yeah I know I know yeah and I was like
that's cause like I hope I hope he's
telling the truth maybe you know I'm too
old to be thrilled by that but I was too
old to be thrilled but it's kind of cool
when someone you grew up watching maybe
knows a little bit I and that's so
pathetic to even admit but yeah I was
like oh thanks Chris because it's part
of why we do this is we're still
insecure yeah but but hundred percent
were and I hope I know is on my eyelid
area I hope I always not hold on the
fact that I don't like myself that much
yeah I'll lose my funny but it was also
cool because I think actors know that
they can't tell always I'm trying to do
stuff I can solve your back problems
with [ __ ] exercises if you think
really I'll solve your back I'll solve
your I'm gonna take you up on that today
to really do it [ __ ] yeah
what do you do for your back well first
of all what do you [ __ ] do so I call
evolution eyes you physically what do I
do
I don't do much man i I think muscle
relaxers everyone else in the Aero idea
I drink alcohol after I take the muscle
this is all very new your eye what do I
do
no I do die I fly I mean you know go we
fly a lot it hurts man just it's it's
rough well you got a disc you got to
build the muscles people think he is
stretch you got to build the stabilizer
muscles yeah I I never knew this until I
became a freak I even follow web
Instagram like squat University I'm
phenom me too for different reasons and
then like dr. sim Pinelli and I got all
these therapists physical therapists
that I follow and they it's an it's it's
amazing yeah do the exercises and and
pain-free you believe it or not a lot of
your back problems starting your your
glutes your ass I believe it yeah we're
gonna work your ass yeah dude do you
tell me that Boozer told me that Kobe
was very hard to get close to absolutely
like he and and and I've heard that from
other players I mean to out Boozer but
you know he said Kobe was a guy who
would never go out with them like he
just and I and I said I was like that
guy was so singular he wasn't interested
in people he was interested in being
great I'm sure he loved his family it's
such a tragedy but that was what was
great about Kobe is that he he was the
dude that he made everyone else better
like his greatness rubbed off on others
like on Team USA but the same way Jordan
did or a little less I think he was the
Jordan of that generation I think no one
will be Jordan because Jordan was Jordan
but but CO and no one will be as good as
Jordan really at some will say LeBron is
better because he's a better passer and
he's bigger but you know Kobe had
Jordan's whale on his heart I think and
on Team USA he it was what he had a
young LeBron a young Dwayne way too
young Carmelo and they all had their
best year right after playing on Team
USA with Kobe because they saw his
habits and like they'd be like oh we're
gonna go out and he's like I'm not going
out I'm waking up at 5:00 a.m. to
[ __ ] shoot and work out do you know
what I what I was reminded of when it
came to Co because I'm not a basketball
fan I don't know a lot about this stuff
but Kobe was always a guy I saw hitting
the three points or whatever
had to be right but I didn't realize
that he also won the slam dunk calm it's
a rookie which I so I was like oh you
also can do that but you didn't even do
that in your in your career he's
primarily a shooter I mean he was a
scorer
he really never had yeah he was like a
will to win score I mean he what Carlos
said to me I think it was him he said he
would he tried to wake up early earlier
than Kobe and beat him at you know like
and Kobe to always be there before him
5:30 in morning mamas mentality that I
mean Kobe III as a basketball fan like I
feel like Kobe was almost like the Ric
Flair of the NBA
well you just couldn't he was like a
heel for so long I feel like even if you
hated him you loved him you loved to
hate him yeah cuz he was hit most of my
friends didn't the world with Knicks
fans in New Yorker and they just hated
him but they would always be like you
just can't argue with the guy you might
be one points in a game my friend
Stavros always said you couldn't ignore
him I mean that's that's just the truth
I mean he he was he was the toughest
cover in the NBA and he was just so
[ __ ] good and then he kind of is cool
to watch it he was such a ruthless
competitor in his prime and then at the
end of his career he became kind of a
mentor to so many young guys so you see
like the instagrams of these E players
who were like that was like my my guy
like everyone felt they had a connection
well he [ __ ] here a meal in up he's
like I don't want to play on the same
court as him yeah he was like he was
calling teammates calling I don't want
that dude on the team yeah he's like I'm
not playing on the court with him it's a
gift